today we're talking about VMware engine
Apache Cassandra and Google cloud next
I'm Roger Martinez and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news from the safety of
home for the past year we've been
working to support customers with VMware
workloads and now we're happy to
announce that the effort has grown into
a fully managed service Google Cloud
VMware engine offers end-to-end support
to migrate and run your VMware
environments on Google cloud platform
check out the blog to learn more Apache
Cassandra is an open-source database
built on a scale out architecture to
support applications with a massive
amount of data to make it easier for
customers to deploy manage and scale
their Cassandra workloads we're
introducing data stacks Astro with
Cassandra as a service try today and
create a Cassandra cluster on Google
cloud in minutes without worrying about
operational overhead Google cloud is
dedicated to helping customers maximize
their business value without maximizing
their budget we offer many tools to help
developers stay on top of their cost but
there are always techniques and tips
that could help you optimize your cost
this blog post covers several high-level
principles that organizations can follow
to ensure that they're getting the most
out of their cloud we spent the last few
months working to evolve next twenty
twenty into a worthwhile digital
experience and now we're pretty proud of
what we've built starting on July 14
join us for a nine week digital event
next on-air will offer fresh content
each week with over 200 sessions in
total all built around providing
compelling content connecting you of
experts and growing your skills if you
want to read more about the
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you